brought to you by watchdogs to hack
everything available on consoles
November 15th and on PC November 29 get
ready to hack the planet watchdogs to is
out this week we've said a sorrowful
goodbye to Aiden Pearce and the Windy
City but now we're saying hello to sunny
San Francisco home of Alcatraz Twitter
read it and now watch dogs too if you
haven't played the first game all you
need a refresher before going in to
watch dogs too and don't worry this week
on in two minutes brought to you by
watch dogs too I'm here to get you up to
speed enter Marcus Holloway who not
unlike the a-team was accused of a crime
he didn't commit evil Corp sorry broom
core pinned him for a high-stakes
robbery using predictive software now if
my experience with predictive text is
anything to go by they got the wrong
ducking guy the software in question is
the intrusive central operating system 2
point 0 you might remember that aiden
pearce shot it down in chicago in the
first game but a beefed-up version got
installed in san francisco it's able to
control everything from vehicles to
mobile phones and it's even capable of
filing police reports even false ones
desperate to clear his name and unhappy
with the way that bloom court uses the
central operating system to control spy
on and sell the data of the people
Marcus teams up with elite hacktivist
group dead sec to take down bloom once
and for all LaMarcus is more nimble than
your average hacker and can park or his
way around the streets while he can tase
enemies for a non-lethal approach his
main weapon of choice is the Thunder
ball it's a billiard ball attached to a
bungee cord ouch all of this takes place
on the vibrant frontlines of burgeoning
technologies hipster beards posh coffees
and flannel shirts San Francisco there's
different regions and familiar sights to
explore so prepare to take advantage of
all that the tech hub of the world has
to offer including 3d printed guns
modified drones and RC cars and
crocs the RC car and the quadcopter can
be used to scout ahead and hack from
afar but just like real life the tool
you'll be using the most will be your
smartphone which is jam-packed full of
apps there's things like a map an
app-based cab company and of course your
selfie camera alongside the main
missions there's operations now
completing these side quests gain dead
SEC more followers for their cause
another way to bump up that Klout score
is to play the game online you can
invade other people's games to hack them
you can take on bounties or even play
the game in coop in terms of social
media strategy it's a little more time
intensive than simply tweeting out a
picture of a cat but you need all the
followers you can get to take on the man
so there's your primary thing you in
watch dogs too for more videos just like
this one make sure to LIKE and subscribe
to gamespot and for cat pictures can
find me on Twitter at Lisa James games
see you next time